Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Pepsi in the UK and the US.
This is "Food Wars."
In the UK, Pepsi comes in
a range of portion sizes,
but these do vary slightly
depending on which type
of Pepsi you're buying.
We used to be able to get mini cans,
but they've been discontinued,
so now you can get classic
Pepsi in four portion sizes.
As a 330-milliliter can,
as a 500-milliliter bottle,
as a 1.5-liter bottle,
and as a 2-liter bottle.
In the US, our Pepsi comes
in these following sizes:
The mini can is the
smallest. 7.5 fluid ounces.
Next one up, the classic
can, 12 fluid ounces.
Then we move up to plastic bottles.
This one is 16.9 fluid ounces.
Then we got the 20-fluid-ounce bottle.
And if that's not enough,
we go up to 1-liter bottle. Liter of cola.
Then moving up a little bit
more, 1.25-liter bottle.
And then our biggest bottle
is the 2-liter bottle.
We can also get glass bottles,
but like the classic
can, they are 12 ounces.
Where regular Pepsi is concerned,
both countries cap out
at a 2-liter bottle.
However, in the UK, we
can go one step further
when it comes to diet and Max Pepsi.
Certain retailers, such as
Iceland or B&M, stock these.
A 3-liter bottle of
Pepsi Max or Pepsi diet.
We finally have something
bigger than America! We did it!
I don't know if that's
a good or a bad thing,
probably bad for the nation's health,
but, you know, nice to
be different for once.
There are some other
slight size differences
for the sugar and sugar-free
options in the UK as well.
For example, in the UK,
we can get a 1.25-liter bottle
of Pepsi Max or Pepsi diet,
which we can't get for the classic Pepsi.
The size differences are largely
down to the UK's sugar tax.
It's a tax which raised
the price of drinks
with more than 5 grams of
sugar per 100 milliliters.
The higher prices reduce the demand
for the full-sugar
versions of soft drinks,
making it less viable to sell
them in large containers,
such as the 3-liter.
But don't worry, because you
can still get sugary Pepsi
in bulk quantities.
Our largest bulk is the
36-can pack of Pepsi,
and that's the 12-ounce cans.
That is 432 fluid ounces of soda,
or 3.375 gallons, of Pepsi.
Now, that pack of cans is at
least available at Sam's Club,
possibly Costco, I don't know,
but I went to Sam's Club,
and unfortunately they
would not let me buy it
without a membership.
So, the best I could do are these pictures
of me with the packs.
That is much larger
than our largest option,
which is this, a 24-pack of cans.
Not only is our multipack
only two-thirds the size
of the American one,
but the cans themselves are also smaller.
A can in the UK contains 330 milliliters,
while a can in the US contains 355.
This means that the total for our 24-pack
comes to 2.09 gallons.
Even if we had a 36-pack,
it would still be smaller
than the American version.
We need three extra cans
to make up the difference.
Here are all the Pepsi
products you'll find in the UK
that you won't find in the US.
Here are all the Pepsi
products from the US
you won't find in the UK.
We'll start with the
exclusive flavors of Pepsi.
In the UK, we have Pepsi Max raspberry.
It's got that really comforting,
extremely nostalgic artificial
blue-raspberry flavor
that you're used to.
On Pepsi's UK website, it
also said they do lime Pepsi,
but I wasn't able to find that
at any of the stores I tried.
Whoops.
We have a few exclusive
Pepsi options of our own.
Starting down here, we
have Pepsi real sugar,
which is in fact made with real sugar,
not the high-fructose-corn-syrup stuff.
Not bad.
We also have Pepsi mango
and Pepsi mango zero sugar.
Seems like a weird fruit choice.
Whoa, smells good.
I'm surprised by how good this is.
And they got the mango zero sugar.
Ooh, already smells drastically different.
It's got a real chemically aftertaste.
Not as good as the regular.
This one here is
Pepsi soda shop cream soda.
Mm.
Very nice.
And the last one, Pepsi vanilla.
I'm gonna be honest with you, Pepsi,
could use a lot more vanilla.
It's, like, vanilla-kissed.
[burps] There it is.
All right, right now what I want to do
is compare the already-tasted
real sugar Pepsi
to the regular Pepsi, which
has high-fructose corn syrup.
Regular Pepsi.
[coughs]
Pepsi's harsher than Coke.
Yeah.
About to say something
somewhat controversial,
but bring it, I want all the smoke.
Real sugar Pepsi tastes just like Coke.
It's just smoother.
This is like ... [burps]
Yeah, this is, like, harsher.
Joe was kind enough to
send me some American Pepsi
as well as some real sugar Pepsi,
so I'm going to do a three-way taste test
and see if I can tell the difference.
Pepsi No. 1.
That's very, like, strong flavor,
quite a syrupy texture to it almost.
Pepsi No. 2.
Yeah, very sweet, but almost
in a more gentle kind of way.
And then No. 3.
More similar in kind of, like,
I'd say sweetness and
mouthfeel to the middle one.
This one is the one that stood
out with the strongest taste,
in my opinion.
These two were very similar,
which is making me think
that these are the British
and real sugar Pepsis.
I'm not sure in which order,
but they had a more gentle taste,
whereas this one seemed
harsher and tasted very syrupy.
So I'm going to guess British,
American real sugar,
American normal Pepsi.
I'm shocked.
These two tasted really similar to me,
and this one stood out, like I said,
and it wasn't particularly pleasant.
Maybe the UK needs to take
a leaf out of America's book
and just put high-fructose
corn syrup in everything.
The other exclusive Pepsi item in the UK
is this Pepsi SodaStream syrup.
For the uninitiated, a
SodaStream is a device
which lets you carbonate
your own drinks at home.
Now, as a sparkling-water obsessive,
I actually own one of these.
So we're going to make our own Pepsi.
So, what you do
is you get one of your
little SodaStream bottles,
fill it to the first line,
and attach it to the machine.
Then you press this button,
and the magic happens.
According to this bottle,
you add about half a cap
of the syrup to this.
That's quite cool.
The first thing I get is just Pepsi.
It tastes a lot like Pepsi Max.
There is a slightly unpleasant aftertaste,
which, I'm not sure
where that's come from.
Maybe I used too much syrup. Who knows.
But I think, yeah, in terms of recreating
a fizzy drink at home with
not a lot of equipment,
it's pretty good.
And that's pretty much it
as far as Pepsi exclusives are concerned,
but we're not stopping there.
PepsiCo owns more beverage brands,
but it does differ depending
on which country you live in.
Now, while in the US,
Keurig Dr Pepper owns 7Up,
in the UK, it's actually owned by PepsiCo,
which means that technically
all of these are Pepsi exclusives.
British 7Up comes in four forms.
As classic 7Up, a 7Up
Free, 7Up cherry Free,
and as a SodaStream syrup.
That's actually not bad.
It doesn't have the unpleasant aftertaste
that the Pepsi one did.
That to me just tastes like 7Up.
One other thing that's worth pointing out
is that in the UK, this
is considered lemonade.
Like, if you walk into
a pub or a restaurant
and ask for a glass of lemonade,
this is what you'll get.
Like, a clear sparkling beverage.
Is that not the case in America?
That is definitely not lemonade,
and it is super weird.
Lemonade is lemon, not juice, right?
But you squeeze lemons
in water and mix it up,
and it's, like, more
refreshing and kind of tart.
And it's closer to a lemon juice.
It's definitely not carbonated.
In front of me we have
something that's brand new,
and it is called Pepsi Nitro.
What is it? Wait, excuse me.
Nitro Pepsi, flip 'em.
Looks to be a tall boy of Pepsi
that, according to the can,
is nitrogen-infused cola
with smaller bubbles and a smoother taste.
[drink fizzes]
Did you hear that? Oh, man!
That's a pretty hard pour, right?
It's not going crazy like a
normal Pepsi would, right?
I'm more excited about the vanilla.
Let's really get really good
audio on this one now. Ready?
[drink fizzes]
Hard pour.
Yeah, it's a little bit smoother.
It still tastes just like Pepsi.
Not as carbonated, which is fine.
Do the vanilla.
Much better. Ooh, that's nice. Yeah.
The issue I'm having with it
is that the only time
soda is that "smooth"
is when it's flat.
I'll f--- with it, but it's just OK.
Pepsi has a few exclusive
brands in the US,
including Mug Root Beer,
Sierra Mist, and Bubly.
They're a carbonated-water brand.
Mug Root Beer.
I was the master at being able
to tell different root beers on taste.
I could tell them apart.
That information is, like, in my DNA.
One of these days we'll
do a root-beer lineup,
a root-beer taste test.
I guarantee I will ace that test.
Yeah, it's taking me back.
Also, they got Sierra Mist.
I hate Sierra Mist.
It's a lemon-lime flavor.
I don't know if they're
competing with Sprite or 7Up.
Always hated this.
Sprite is better. 7Up is better.
Sierra Mist tastes the way
fruit-flavored shampoo
smells, if that makes sense.
[burps] OK.
This'll be my ranking
system, from best to worst.
So, first we're going to go strawberry.
No, I do not like that.
Cherry.
I think these all might be bad.
That one's a little better
than the strawberry one.
Pineapple.
Nope, woof!
Grapefruit, ugh.
Low expectations on this one.
Oh, my God, that smells like an armpit.
Oh, man, if I went into a public restroom
and it smelled like this, I would run out.
No!
Oh-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho-ho!
Yeah, that's the worst one.
Lime. Can't screw up lime, come on.
Congrats, lime, you're
the least offensive.
Peach.
What the hell happened?
Why are these all so bad?
Raspberry.
Oh, man, the smell of that.
It says natural flavor.
It does not taste natural at all.
At all. At all.
Ah, blackberry.
OK, that's the best one,
but it's not very good.
And last and not -- mango.
OK, so we had the mango,
so they know how to flavor
things mango properly.
The mango Pepsi's fantastic.
I mean, yeah, these two are the best one.
They're not very good.
Bubly is not very good.
How could they screw these up this bad?
PepsiCo also owns Mountain
Dew in the UK and the US,
but that is a story for another episode.
Story time. Anyone ever
remember or heard of New Coke?
Well, you can thank Pepsi for that.
Once upon a time,
Coca-Cola was actually
losing market share,
and Pepsi put out a
very popular ad campaign
where people were blind
taste-testing Coke and Pepsi
and picking Pepsi.
So Coke panicked,
and they pushed to market
a beverage called New Coke,
which is basically Coke
that was supposed to
taste more like Pepsi.
Guess what? Huge marketing blunder.
Not only did Coca-Cola fans get annoyed
that they changed the formula
of a beverage they liked,
but all New Coke was doing was
giving Pepsi more attention.
Either way, just 79 days
after introducing New Coke,
Coke announced that
they'd be bringing back
the original drink,
called Coca-Cola Classic.
And you will maybe notice,
for, like, 20 years,
Coca-Cola was called Coca-Cola Classic.
It had "Classic" on there.
Have you ever wondered why?
That's because they wanted
to make it perfectly clear,
this is not that New Coke that you hated
from 1988 or whatever.
So, Pepsi, they had their day in the sun,
but to be honest, I mean,
Coke is clearly the more dominant brand.
Speaking of product failures,
remember Crystal Pepsi?
That was widely considered
to be one of the biggest
product failures ever.
Time magazine put Crystal Pepsi at No. 3
on the biggest-fails list.
Thrillist called it "Soda
World's Greatest Fail."
But why?
Soda sales were stagnant
in the early '90s,
with consumers instead opting
for clear and caffeine-free sodas.
Former Pepsi marketing exec David Novak
pitched a drink that was both,
and Crystal Pepsi was born.
The recipe was developed by
food scientist Surinder Kumar,
and Pepsi ended up with a clear drink
that maintained an almost
identical taste to Classic Pepsi.
They rushed it out in time
for the 1993 Super Bowl.
It was backed by a $40
million ad campaign,
and they did sell about half a
billion dollars' worth of it.
But by March of '93,
the hype quickly faded.
Consumers did not love the new flavor,
and the concept was even parodied by "SNL"
in a "crystal gravy" sketch.
Hilarious.
Roughly one year after launch,
Crystal Pepsi was discontinued.
But if you never got the chance to try it,
there's still hope for you.
Pepsi's bringing Crystal
Pepsi back for a limited time
to celebrate its 30th anniversary.
You can't buy it in stores,
but you can enter a contest
by sending them a picture of yourself
from the '90s on Twitter.
Here is my entry.
I've got a story of my own.
Remember that time when
Pepsi briefly became
the world's sixth-most-powerful
military force?
It all started in 1959
at the American National
Exhibition in Moscow.
When a discussion between
the then vice president, Richard Nixon,
and Nikita Khrushchev became heated,
a Pepsi exec called
Donald Kendall stepped in
to hand Khrushchev a glass
of Pepsi to cool him down.
Khrushchev enjoyed Pepsi so
much that arrangements were made
for it to be imported
from the US to Russia.
As part of the deal, Pepsi
even negotiated a monopoly,
locking Coca-Cola out of the country.
The drink's popularity exploded
in an otherwise uncontested market.
But there was one problem: payment.
The Russian ruble wasn't accepted
outside of the Soviet Union,
so the Russians had to come up
with an alternative arrangement.
They settled on a
universal currency: vodka.
Russia traded thousands of
cases of Stolichnaya vodka
for Pepsi syrup throughout
the '60s and the '70s.
However, they did run
into problems in the '80s.
Pepsi's popularity in Russia
combined with a boycott
due to the Soviet-Afghan War
meant that vodka just wasn't
going to cut it anymore.
Here's where things get fun.
In the spring of 1989,
Pepsi and the Soviet Union agreed a deal
whereby Pepsi would be
given 17 old submarines
and three warships.
They would then sell them for
scrap to pay for the Pepsi.
Therefore, for a short period of time,
Pepsi controlled the
sixth-most-powerful navy in the world.
Now that is a food war.
Here's everything in a Pepsi in the US.
Carbonated water,
high-fructose corn syrup,
caramel color, sugar,
phosphoric acid, caffeine,
citric acid, natural flavors.
Here is everything in Pepsi in the UK.
Carbonated water, sugar,
color (caramel E150d), phosphoric acid,
and flavorings including caffeine.
Now, obviously Pepsi
won't go into specifics
on the flavorings used,
because the recipe is a
closely guarded secret.
Or is it?
Pepsi was invented in
North Carolina in 1893
by a man named Caleb Bradham.
First it was called Brad's Drink,
but then they renamed it Pepsi in 1898.
It comes from the fact
that it was marketed
as relieving dyspepsia,
another word for indigestion.
It's giving me indigestion,
so that's weird.
However, in 1923, the
original Pepsi-Cola company
went bankrupt due to
fluctuating sugar prices
after World War I.
As part of the bankruptcy filing,
Bradham had to release
the recipe for Pepsi,
as it was a company asset,
and it's still publicly
available to this day.
So you can make your own Pepsi at home
simply by combining sugar,
water, caramel color,
lime juice, phosphoric
acid, alcohol, lemon juice,
orange juice, cinnamon oil,
nutmeg, coriander (cilantro),
and petitgrain, which is an essential oil
extracted from the leaves and
twigs of bitter orange trees.
Yeah, just those things.
The rights to Pepsi were eventually bought
by a man named Charles Guth,
who was then the president
of the Loft Corporation,
which later merged into PepsiCo.
They of course claim
that they reformulated the
recipe after the takeover,
but the original is still
there for all to see.
Enough with the history lesson.
What is the difference
between US and UK Pepsi?
That is why we are here.
First, let's talk about acids.
Both the UK and the US acidify their Pepsi
with phosphoric acid.
It's a weak acid which is
primarily used as a fertilizer.
When added to foods, it
provides a tangy taste,
but it's also been linked
to causing kidney stones
as well as osteoporosis.
The US also uses citric acid in its Pepsi.
Citric acid is a more common
and generally safer acidifier in foods,
but it's one of the things in sodas
that will cause tooth enamel to erode
after repeated consumption.
I happen to have some of that right here.
Whoo!
That's sour.
Another major difference in Pepsi
is that in the US, we sweeten our Pepsi
with high-fructose corn
syrup in addition to sugar.
High-fructose corn syrup is everywhere
in American sodas and candies.
Government subsidies make it super-cheap
for American farmers to grow corn,
and food manufacturers use
corn syrup to save money
instead of importing sugarcane
from places like Mexico and Brazil.
Corn syrup is hard to
find at all in the UK.
We did manage to track
down this small bottle,
but only in a specialist grocery store.
Even then, it's just regular corn syrup
and not high-fructose.
The good news is, is
that it isn't actually
any worse for you than sugar.
The main impact is on the taste,
which explains why we have a
Pepsi made with real sugar.
Here it is, a version of the US drink
which does not contain any corn syrup.
This version actually has
the exact same ingredients
as the UK Pepsi.
Anything else to note?
Well, our old friend
caramel color is back.
In the UK, it's listed as caramel E150d,
while the US just lists caramel color.
This is a somewhat
controversial food coloring
used to give things like Pepsi
a distinctive golden-brown tinge.
There are four classes of caramel color,
classes I through IV.
Studies have suggested
that the production of classes III and IV
create a byproduct that
may put people at risk
of developing cancer.
Of course.
Why can't we enjoy anything?
While the FDA has stopped
short of banning caramel color,
the state of California added
it to its Proposition 65
list of chemicals known to cause cancer
and birth defects or reproductive harm.
Are these potentially harmful
caramel colors in our Pepsi?
Well, in the UK, the answer is yes.
We know that class IV caramel
color is used in the UK
because sulfite ammonia
caramel has the E number E150d,
which is on the list.
What about in the US, where it just says
caramel color without specifics?
We reached out to Pepsi
to ask which class they use over here.
And their answer was: nothing.
They said they would not comment
on the specific ingredients
due to proprietary issues.
Yeah, guys?
You're afraid that
detail's gonna really help,
uh,
cut into your competition?
So, your Pepsi may or may not
be putting you at risk of cancer.
So glad we cleared that up.
In the US, a can of Pepsi
contains the following.
150 calories,
0 grams of fat,
41 grams of carbohydrates,
and all those are sugars,
and 30 milligrams of sodium.
A can of Pepsi in the UK
contains the following.
135 calories,
0 grams of fat,
36 grams of carbs,
of which 36 grams are sugars,
and 4 milligrams of sodium.
Obviously the alarming
stat here is the sugar.
Just one can of US Pepsi
contains 80% of your
daily sugar allowance.
Really, one?
Ugh.
The UK statistic is slightly better,
at just 72% of your daily allowance,
but that is still a lot of sugar
in a relatively small amount of liquid.
There's also some caffeine in Pepsi.
A 12-ounce can contains
38 milligrams of caffeine,
which is about half as much
as an 8-ounce cup of coffee.
I of course am drinking
both Pepsi and coffee at the same time.
Pepsi doesn't openly disclose
its caffeine content in the UK,
but according to a website I found
called caffeineinformer.com,
a can of UK Pepsi Max contains
42 milligrams of caffeine.
The US equivalent of Pepsi
Max is Pepsi zero sugar,
but a can, not pictured here,
has over 69 milligrams of caffeine.
N-n-n-n-nice.
[air horn goes off]
Making it significantly more caffeinated
than the UK version.
But the good news: According to the FDA,
you need to consume 1,200
milligrams of caffeine
in a short period of time to
put your health in danger.
That's about 18 cans of Pepsi zero sugar.
I like a challenge, let's go.
Ugh!
Can I drink a carbonated
water without burping?
Wait. Ah, damn it.
I'm sorry. [burps] I tried.